مشاهدينا الكرام هذا هو اليوم الثالث عشر
لهذا القتال المتواصل وايضا هذا اليوم
الثالث والاخير من هذه الهدنه الرابعه بين
الطرفين طبعا جهود تمديد هذه الهدنه
مستمره ولكن القصف وتبادل اطلاق النار
والاشتباكات هي سيده الموقف في عموم
البلاد وتحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم اذا ما
ذهبنا مباشره الى العاصمه الخرطوم بشكل
سريع فنحن نتحدث عن قصف بالطيران قالت
قوات الدعم السريع عنا قوات الجيش
السوداني نفذته في هذه المناطق مناطق شرق
مدينه خرطوم بحري وتحديدا عند نهر النيل
الازرق في هذه النقطه اذا ما تحدثنا عن
هذه مدينه الخرطوم بحري
مركز مدينه الخرطوم بحري فالمنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه من نهر النيل الازرق
كانت مسرحه عمليات وتحديدا شاهدنا قبل
قليل صور
للدخان متصاعد من هذه المناطق من منطقه كف
المنطقه الصناعيه في منطقه الشرق النيل
البحري تحديدا شمال نهر النيل الازرق اذا
ما اقتربنا اكثر من هذه الزاويه هذه هي
الزاويه الاساسيه التي تدور فيها العمليات
العسكريه لان الجيش السوداني يعزز من
قواته القادمه من جهه الشماليه وقوات
الدعم السريع تعزز من قواتها القادمه من
المناطق الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه في
اطلاله اقرب على هذه المنطقه فنحن نتحدث
عن هذا المربع الذي ترتكز فيه العمليات
العسكريه على هذه المنطقه المنطقه المربع
الامني الذي يضم المطار ومقر قياده القوات
المسلحه وقصر الجمهوري ما يربط بين
الخرطوم بحري ومدينه الخرطوم اربعه جسور
وجزء كبري كوبر او جسر كوبر وجسر النيل
الازرق وجسر المكنمر وايضا جسر جزيره
توتري هنا يقع مكتب الجزيره حيث استمعنا
قبل قليل
لمراسلنا هيثم اوت في هذه تحديدا في مكتب
الجزيره في هذه النقطه واستمعنا لاصوات
القذائف التي تتساقط في محيط هذه المنطقه
المكتب مكتب الجزيره لا يبعد الا حوالي
اقل من اثنين كيلو متر او كيلو و700 متر
فقط عن القصر الجمهوري الذي يشهد
الاشتباكات في القصر الجمهوري هنا تتمركز
قوات الدعم السريعه التي تقول بان الجيش
السوداني قصف اليوم هذه المنطقه مستهدفا
تمركز قوات او قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
القصر الجمهوري الجيش السوداني يقول انه
ايضا في المناطق الجنوبيه يقوم بعمليات
تنشيط واسعه بحثا عن مقاتلي الدعم السريع
وهناك حرب شوارع ان صح التعبير في هذه
المنطقه ايضا القوات الدعم السريع تتمركز
في المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من مطار
الخرطوم الدولي الذي خرج عن الخدمه منذ
الساعات الاولى لهذه المعارك القوات الدعم
السريع تتمركز هنا وتقول بان قوات الجيش
ايضا تستهدفها في هذه
في المقابل تقول قوات المسلحه السودانيه
او الجيش السوداني بان قوات الدعم السريع
تحاول الهجوم باتجاه هذه النقطه نقطه مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه حيث تتمركز
ايضا او توجد قوات الجيش السوداني ليكون
هذا المربع والمربع الاكثر اشتعالا حوالي
اثنين كيلو متر في العمق وخمسه الى سته
كيلو مترات الى الشرق او الى الغرب واثنين
كيلو متر الى الشمال وهذه هي المنطقه او
المربع الاكثر اشتعالا خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه ولكنه ليس الوحيد قوات
الجيش السوداني قالت لان القوات الدعم
السريع نفذت هجوما على مقر قياده او
الحاكميه حاكم الولايه في الجنينه عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور في اقصى غربيه البلاد
على الحدود بين تشاد والسودان وقالت قوات
الجيش الجيش ان الدعم السريع نفذ هذا
الهجوم الذي احبط قوات الجيش على مدينه
الجنين طبعا نعرف بان المنطقه الغربيه
والمنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه هي مناطق
ارتكاز تاريخي لقوات الدعم السريع ومنها
تتقدم قوات الدعم السريعه باتجاه العاصمه
السودانيه لتدفع بتعزيزات عسكريه باتجاه
العاصمه بينما تقوم قوات الجيش بمزيد من
التعزيزات من الجهه الشماليه باتجاه
العاصمه الخرطوم لتبقى العاصمه الخرطوم هي
مسرح العمليات حتى هذه اللحظه مع هذه
الهدنه الرابعه التي تدخل ساعتها الاخيره
في انتظار اما انت يتم تمديد هذه الهدنه
وقد يتوقف القتال واما ان تنهر هذه الهدنه
ويزداد القتال وتزداد حده القتال وتحديدا
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم هذه
المعلومات بطبيعه الحال بحاجه الى تفصيل
وتحليل وسيكونان مع وسيله وزين في بقيه
هذه التغطيه